today I'm going to put this weird thing
on my head and communicate with gpt4
using nothing but my thoughts growing up
my dad would always tell me damn it son
you need to use your brain more but I
never fully understood what he meant
until now the human brain is the most
complex machine in nature and how it
really works is still a mystery what we
do know is that it's always emitting
measurable electrical impulses called
brain waves scientists have been
measuring these waves for decades using
electroencephalograms or eegs that
connect tons of electrodes to your Dome
you've likely seen them in movies Like
Clockwork Orange but I was able to get
my hands on this futuristic device
called the crown a compact and stylish
electroencephalogram that you could
totally wear on a Tinder date without
looking weird it's the same basic idea
as elon's neuraling except you won't
need to drill a hole into your skull and
best of all it's got a JavaScript SDK
that we can use to hack into our own
brain waves naturally my first thought
was to connect my brain to gpt4 you give
myself superhuman intelligence and
that's what I did which makes me the
smartest man in the world you're about
to get a glimpse into the future a
transhuman cyborg future where every
human while every Rich human anyway will
have all the knowledge in the world not
just at their fingertips but at their
brain tips the Poors will have these as
well but they'll be used by the CIA to
make you dumber like the moment you get
thirsty you'll be served in
advertisement for overpriced sugar water
that will slowly kill you the crown
device has a price tag of about one
thousand dollars it sits on the back of
your head and has a bunch of tiny
electrodes that measure your brain waves
it hooks up to a mobile app via
Bluetooth or Wi-Fi then streams your
brain's data Into The Ether the app also
provides helpful utilities like how to
improve focus but I don't care about
that I want access to the raw data which
we can easily get in Json format via its
JavaScript SDK But first you need to
know a little bit more about brain waves
when you're asleep your brain emits low
frequency delta waves around 2 Hertz
these waves increase their frequency
when you're awake and relaxed as they
become Alpha Waves around 10 Hertz and
then finally when you become highly
focused like when solving a coding
problem or playing chess they increase
to 35 Hertz and these are gamma waves
and that's what we care most about
measuring because they're useful for
actually controlling things things
brainwave patterns are highly Dynamic
and can rapidly change depending on a
person's cognitive state mental
processes and external stimuli however
neurosity the company that makes the
crown provides a dashboard where you can
train algorithms to recognize your own
custom thought patterns like currently
I'm training it to understand when I'm
thinking about biting into a lemon I
just imagine biting into a sour ass
lemon and then relax when it tells me to
after doing this about 30 times it will
learn how to recognize that thought
pattern So currently I am not thinking
about biting into a lemon and the
chart's not moving but now as I start
thinking about biting into a lemon the
chart goes wild that's pretty crazy and
it's accurate to the point of being
somewhat frightening it is somewhat time
consuming but you can train all kinds of
different patterns like I also did right
hand pinch and tongue based on my wife's
recommendations now that it knows how to
understand my brain waves let's write
some code that can do something useful
like communicate with gpt4 here I have a
basic node.js project created with npm
net from there I can install the
neurosity SDK then in the code I'll go
ahead and import it and first step is to
initialize it with your device ID the
device ID can be found in the mobile app
next we log in with our email and
password because a crown can have
multiple users and now I can start
reading my brain with JavaScript by
simply calling neurosity brainwaves raw
then subscribe to a stream of that data
well technically it's an observable
because it uses rxjs under the hood if
we console log it it spits out an
overwhelming feat of data it has a
sampling rate of 256 Hertz which means
we'll get 256 samples per second they're
batched into 16 samples that emit
approximately every 62.5 milliseconds in
addition the brain waves are broken down
into eight different channels so you get
these huge objects with tons of numbers
that look like this if you went to brain
college you might be able to take this
data and analyze it yourself but luckily
neurosity provides a better way it
provides observables for specific States
like calm and focus that means we can
subscribe to those mental States and
then run code as a side effect but the
coolest thing is that we can also
recognize those thought patterns that we
trained earlier like if we want to
listen to left hand pinch we can call
neurosity Kinesis followed by the name
of the event and it's this feature that
allows me to turn myself into a cyborg
what I'm able to do now is install the
open AI SDK where I can authenticate and
access gpt4 the API is dead simple to
use all we need to do is call create
chat completion specify the model as
gpt4 and then send it an array of
messages the result is no different than
what you would get from chat GPT in the
browser once I have that message I can
do whatever I want with it like what I
can do next is use a text to voice model
to convert the text into voice as an
audio file this is your president
speaking subscribe to fireship on
YouTube before I drone strike your ass
and then transmit it directly to a
Bluetooth earpiece the implications of
this are huge because now when I show up
late to my daily stand-up meeting all I
have to do is think about right hand
pinch to ask chatgpt to come up with an
excuse for why I was late for work or if
I'm taking a test like the bar exam and
there's a question I don't know the
answer to all I have to do is think
about biting a lemon which will transmit
a signal to my camera enabled glasses
which will then upload that image to GPT
4 and provide an answer that's
guaranteed to get me in the top eighty
percent or maybe I could become a super
soldier then stick out my tongue to blow
up a village of innocent civilians the
possibilities are endless when you start
thinking like a JavaScript program
cyborg thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one